all right guys
bang bang about gagan here with me thank
you so much for doing this
thanks for having me pop i'm so excited
absolutely
let's just jump right into online
education i feel like uh
over the last couple of years uh people
are waking up to the fact that
they want to learn they want to be
better educated on either specific
topics or just general knowledge
uh but maybe the path of uh going to a
traditional university uh
taking on hundreds of thousands of
dollars of student debt may not be
the path for everyone doesn't mean that
it can't be helpful just being said it's
probably not for every single person
and you've been in the online education
space for a long time so kind of just
talk to us about like what you've seen
uh and how this industry has evolved
over the last few years
yeah it's so funny because online
education was like
a black mark on a startup's uh resume if
you were talking about it back when we
started in 2009
uh when we started udemy people
basically
said oh online education i don't invest
in that or
online education huh i even had a
quote from paul graham that he called it
a uh a tar pit or a pit hole i can't
remember which one but
the point is like uh back in 2009 people
didn't believe that
learning on the internet was a thing and
here we are in 2021
and i'm amazed amazed
at how optimistic people are about
learning over the internet and the
average person i interact with today
is looking at the internet as like this
vast source of knowledge
you know everything from being able to
google or wikipedia or youtube
basic knowledge to taking advanced
online courses like cohort based courses
people are opening up to the idea that
these courses might actually be better
than the courses that they took in
college and that inflection point is
coming because
both colleges and sort of mainstream
education are losing their appeal
as rising you know costs with rising
costs
and as online learning is increasing in
its quality
and that's a big shift that's happened
recently so that's why we're so excited
about cohort based courses
because they represent a major change in
a major improvement in the quality of
the online learning experience
one of the things that's fascinating is
this idea that so many people were
previously
uh aware of online education but they
kind of stayed away from it from an
investment standpoint
uh was that because there was a lack of
belief that like it was effective do you
think it maybe was they didn't think
they could make money
investing those types of businesses
maybe kind of a mix any insight into
maybe what was driving
um you know folks from kind of avoiding
this space previously
the internet in 2009 and the vc
landscape was so
different today if you come to someone
with a crazy idea about a new market
that people haven't thought of investing
in in the past like let's say you
started you came in with a pet food
company right or you came in with a
company i don't know
about like selling selling selling uh
pla plan advice
right people are much more open-minded
that there might be the next big thing
on the internet
might be in a sector or industry that
they did not expect
whereas back in 2009 there were a much
narrower and clearer sets of areas in
which people felt like they could make
money
and they mostly stayed in their lanes
like the majority of investors
had three to five categories they were
looking at and that's what they invested
in
so not to say that there weren't
investors who were looking more broadly
but the majority of investors weren't
so that's the major change it's not just
online learning
it's digital healthcare it's you know
fitness it's entertainment broadly
and it's owned content like own content
was never something vcs would invest
in in the past it's non-platform
businesses
there's such a wide and then of course
crypto like
what a crazy wild idea that came out of
nowhere over the last decade right so
you have a number of these new sectors
and investors have sort of changed their
thought process
there's also just like 10x more
investors and more money going into
startups because there's
so much better returns and so i think
that's a large part of it
and online education uh in specifics got
hot over the last decade because we
showed that there's money there
i mean udemy is gonna you know udemy is
a
multi-billion dollar company with
hundreds of millions of dollars in
transactional volume and revenue
and nobody believed that was possible
but now that udemy coursera udacity
master class
kajabi teachable all these companies are
putting up billion dollar numbers either
in valuation
or in revenue or gross market
merchandise value
uh i think a lot of investors are like
wow okay this is a big trend
and now if i don't invest in it i
probably am missing out on whatever the
next
set of opportunities are going to be in
this market
for sure and one of the things obviously
that you've uh
kind of iterated on and improved over
time uh
is this model that uh is now called a
cohort based
uh course maybe describe a little bit
about the difference between cohort
based versus the other models
and why you're so bullish on this being
a highly effective way for
education to be kind of shared on the
internet
so i think since time immemorial there
have been two ways to learn
there's been the auto didactic way
i'm going to go and learn on my own
right i'm going to read
books i'm going to have a textbook
or i'm going to like go and do research
usually it has to do with reading until
about
roughly the like mid to you know 20th
century when it started to become video
based so you could buy dvds
and then of course the big online
learning revolution was
hey you could just watch videos on the
internet and you could pay maybe ten
fifty dollars
and learn a subject and that was a huge
revolution for autodidactic learning
um historically though autodidactic
learning has always been a small
percentage of the spend in learning
and actually the bigger spend in
learning has almost
always been in the other format which is
cohort based courses
so if you think about any professional
education you've ever been in any
seminar you've attended
even conferences and then of course
universities in any k-12 school
they're all cohort based and the
difference is that you don't learn
entirely on your own
you have a requirement an expectation to
do homework or projects
or you know learn and read material in
advance
but there is structure to your learning
someone has gone through and curated an
experience
that has a start and end date and
everyone learns at the same time
together so in a
seminar people start in the morning they
end in the afternoon and you're on the
same group at
school you have the same class from you
know
september all the way until august
sorry september until until may and so
co-work-based courses have always been a
thing but they haven't been a big thing
on the internet
until zoom and slack came around right
and so now that zoom and slack are big
the internet is now
ready to take the mantle of cohort based
courses
and apply the same thing that we applied
to video based courses or
to auto didactic learning we're now
doing it to learning that's more
advanced learning that has
more structure to it where the
instructor is taking you from point a to
point b
so when you start thinking through uh
how to build a company for the trade i'm
an investor in maven the company you run
today
uh and i've got one of uh the courses uh
on the platform
but how did you go from the insights of
okay the world is changing there's now
new tools available
people might want to learn in this kind
of old model but in a new venue on the
internet
um to actually let's start a company
around this and we think that we can
build a product and raise capital and
kind of commercialize it to some degree
there's so many ways to come up with a a
startup idea
i'm going to tell you my philosophy and
it works for me because i'm a you know
i'm my own
type of entrepreneur and i think it
works for a majority of entrepreneurs
but there are other ways
i don't start companies uh with the idea
that i want to start a company
that's just not how i get inspiration
i'm not excited to make a lot of money
or build a really big organization that
like you know look at me i'm on forbes
like that's just not my
mentality going in i'm happy to be that
type of entrepreneur and i'm not going
to complain about the benefits
but that's not my focus my focus is
uh i like to live my daily life and
to start to think about what's next in
the context of
what would i like to do for fun and what
would i like to do
to have an impact on the world and
almost always that involves
joining companies starting projects this
creative phase
is highly um focused not on
oh i need to build a company because i
think that wraps my ego too much
in the goal and instead it's a process
of just uh learning and and trying to
figure out what's interesting
and so i spent 12 months and this time
this is my third time starting a startup
probably like seventh or tenth company
but but third startup
and this time i actually did in a really
structured way i told myself
my fiance was going to business school
at oxford
and i basically said she starts in
september and ends in the following
september so it's 12 months
and i'm going to give myself 12 months
to figure out what i want to do next
and i had no idea what that was going to
be i looked into politics
i looked into conserve conservation in
africa i looked into
writing a book and then i started
writing on the internet
and it was kind of around that time
where i was like wow
the way that i keep learning how to
write a book and writing on the internet
is taking online courses i took
tucker max's course about writing a book
and then i took david perell's course on
writing online
and that's when the insight came to me
was like oh my god this
is huge what an opportunity the types of
courses
i'm taking today that are fully digital
are completely different from the video
based courses we were creating on udemy
like back in 2009 when i wanted to learn
about education
or learn about startups i went online
and read a lot and i watch a lot of
youtube videos
and so i noticed a new pattern happening
in my auto didactic self
right which was hey i wanna
i'm learning through video based courses
i'm interacting with people i'm going on
zoom
i'm doing exercises and then bring them
to my group of peers
and that's sort of when i started to get
interested in the idea that cohort based
courses could be a business
then i started diving deeper into core
based courses and just sort of went down
the rabbit hole
and i explored all sorts of different
options i thought about just
launching the course myself and i did a
few of those as test runs to learn more
about the market
i also went and worked with businesses
that were already building core based
courses and sort of consulted or advised
for them
so i worked with you know a guy in the
eu
who was building a court-based course
for entrepreneurs
i worked with a company in the states
that was building core based courses
and uh at this point i hadn't even named
the category i just sort of knew that
these were something in education that
involved zoom
let's call it that then at some point
you know sorry yeah so and once you kind
of
said okay like this is a new thing what
do you do from there
right so then i get to the point where
i'm like oh this is a new thing
what are the ways i could tackle this
market and i just let myself
think about them and one day it hits me
the right model for this market is a
platform-based approach
because of the way the internet is
because of the way things are
and this is like a choice of business
model i think there are usually
three to five options for how you can go
and i really believe in being ruthless
about picking the right option because
the option is going to decide
everything for the future and so we
could have been a creator of
core based courses i could have been a
publisher you know
i could have decided to be a marketplace
where we're gonna sell cover-based
courses on behalf of instructors
and eventually i could have built just
built software we decided this platform
approach was gonna be the right one
um and then i went and started to test
that out and
raise money for it and and build it
what's fascinating to me about
um kind of the path that you took is uh
one word that i kind of just want to
think of you i think of
is focus right uh the the thing that uh
people internally know that maybe people
externally don't know is
for a long time you didn't have a name
for the company right it was just you i
think you even had raised money at one
point
uh from investors and still didn't have
an official name for the business and so
maybe talk through just like the
trade-offs of like how did you evaluate
uh what should you focus on what maybe
isn't as
important um and then kind of how you
divide up your time and attention across
the
the you know multitude of things that uh
you could pursue
you know in the early stages where uh
resources are light and there's just a
lot of work to do
in my mind startups have a very clear
pattern
of how they are built and i
strictly follow that pattern and focus
all my attention in any given stage
within that pattern
of what is the highest
value thing or the most important thing
i need to accomplish in order to get to
the next stage
so in the ideation stage you just heard
me talk about
my goal is just to figure out like what
do i want to do next and to leave it
really broad so that stage
needs to be highly actually goal
goal agnostic essentially and just a
creative phase so there's a creative
phase that's the first phase in a
startup
the second phase is you have a vision or
an inkling of an idea
and you have to test whether or not that
idea has any sort of legs and has what i
would call product market fit
but your kind of product market fit has
multiple stages so the first stage is
just
um do i think that this has a chance of
having product market fit
and that's the stage that you met me
that we met each other in which was
i thought co-work-based courses were
going to be big i'd already seen a bunch
of courses be successful
but i didn't know for sure whether or
not we could build a platform and i
didn't know the risks
or costs associated with that and so i
was pretty ruthlessly focused
on just proving that out and so for the
first six months
you know our team was almost all
business people there weren't a lot of
engineers on the team because i didn't
think the risk was
whether or not we could build a great
product i thought the risk was whether
or not we could sell the product
and so i spent all my time trying to
work with people like you
and you were kind enough to be one of
our you you were kind of to be our first
instructor
and i have also been most successful
instructor
but i learned a lot from working with
you and with lee jin and lenny ruchitsky
and uh and saha lavinia our first four
instructors and through that process
i started to say okay this has an option
and this is
and we started to refine right we
learned that for example
four-week courses might be a little too
long maybe we should shorten them a
little bit so we can do one or two-week
courses
and they're just as effective and
actually students like them more
we learned how to interact with an
instructor like you like you've done a
great job
bringing on colton right having a
partner is a big thing so we know now
that having a partner is an important
part of this whole process and we need
to make sure there's room for that so we
figured out our revenue share during
that time
so this discovery period was all about
narrowing it on product market fit
and then we said okay we've got it we've
got this
you know we've got this thing we think
it's going to work we're going to start
introducing it to the world
and that's when we launched the name and
the website and
now we're in this phase of okay we've
proven that with a few people we can
definitely get courses off the ground
and make them really successful so you
know we've done over a million dollars
of course sales
they're really uh growing and it looks
like that's going to be a big
opportunity
but how do we then make this accessible
to a wider variety of people because we
think the vision of
maven is that there are thousands or
hundreds of thousands of
potential instructors out there and not
just 10
and so we can't handle everyone so now
we're in the phase of just
proving that we have a product and an
offering
that can uh meet the next phase which is
can we prove that a lot of instructors
love maven and we're starting to prove
that
so you can see that i'm very phase
driven in my approach
and focus on whatever the highest risk
potential
thing that could could kill the business
and what's the highest benefit
that could make the business successful
and everything else is just noise
yeah it's fascinating because uh i think
people who have an academic
understanding
uh or maybe uh have never built a
company before
or invested in them usually think of
entrepreneurs as risk takers
right people who seek out risk they
enjoy it they thrive on it
uh but in reality uh and what exactly
you're highlighting here
is they actually are risk mitigators
right they think of all of the risks
and they work to try to remove that risk
from the business because it increases
the odds of success
um if you can kind of do it effectively
over and over and over again uh you end
up building a pretty big business pretty
successful business and so it's it's
fascinating to just kind of hear you
articulate that
in the way that you did for me i i think
what's so fascinating about
um this entire experience right i mean
we've done over 400 students i think now
through the uh
the cohort based sessions and
there's this element of uh information
transfer
right so information that we've put
together um
and kind of vetted and made sure it's
high quality it's effective
it really delivers on the promise uh
that people are looking for when they
come
but also there's an element of the
community and i've been shocked i think
from my perspective
uh how many people at the end tell us
you know look one of the most important
parts of this or one of the
most enjoyable parts of it was actually
the other people i went through
uh the course with and so for you uh you
know you've got this really interesting
experience where you saw kind of those
uh single player
online courses before right so i take it
and i don't really have that community
aspect
do you also see that across other
courses uh on the platform where
folks say that the community aspect is
kind of a core thing or is that
something that maybe is specific to
bitcoin and kind of the crypto industry
it's universal people
buy cohort based courses for the promise
of the outcomes
they're always outcome focused like i
want to get a job in crypto i'm going to
take pops crypto course
i want to learn more about this subject
i'm going to take
you know this person's course they
almost always
leave uh with a feeling of community and
so if you read the feedback before and
after
it's so different because people don't
realize how valuable it is
just meet like a hundred other people
who are as into this thing
that they're into and also the uh
knock-on effects of that
are super um valuable right so think
about college right
a lot of people like the nps for college
is shockingly high
net promoter score for college people
actually still really love college
and if you read uh why people love
college
very few people will talk about the
education almost everyone will say
yeah those were the best learning
experiences of my life
uh in terms of like growing up and
mostly in terms of people they met
and so you know cohorts based courses
cover-based courses provide that same
level of magic
they have this magic of like you're
going into breakout rooms you're meeting
people on the same interest they have
similar backgrounds
and you know as we get better and better
at building these courses we're going to
get better at matching people with their
friends
and we're going to get better at making
sure that that experience
is truly um truly special
of the community that they find and i
think people are going to continue to
take these courses not
for just the educational aspect which
you can get in a book or on a wikipedia
article sometimes
but actually for the accountability the
rigor that it forces you to have
as well as the community what's up guys
bang bang
i hope you're enjoying this conversation
but before we go any further i want to
quickly tell you about today's sponsor
blockfi blockfy's got four different
financial products for crypto investors
you can deposit crypto and earn up to
8.6 apy
in an interest bearing account you can
deposit crypto and take out a us dollar
loan against your crypto collateral
you can use our cryptocurrency exchange
and have no trading fees
or you can get a new bitcoin rewards
credit card it's a normal credit card
that when you swipe you get bitcoin back
rather than cash back or airline miles
i'm an investor in the business and a
very happy user
i think you will be too when you go to
blockfy.com
pomp again blockfy.com go check it out
and let me know what you think
all right let's get back into this
conversation i hope you enjoy it
yeah and and i guess part of this is um
you know i would ask you how are you
scaling a marketplace you've used the
word platform a few times
um so maybe talk a little bit just about
the the product and how you see
uh building that right early on you said
that you had a lot of
more business folks because you felt
that was a risk of could you actually
onboard
uh the instructors and kind of use them
to
uh want to do this but it sounds like
now you've really focused on the
software
and building uh out the product so just
talk a little bit you know marketplace
platform or how you think about that how
you scale it
yeah to be fair we're still at the point
where business focus is the main way
that we deliver
value to instructors so uh our main
value right now
is if you've never taught a cohort based
course before it is
way harder than it sounds you have to
figure out how to build a community you
have to figure out
great content and if you're charging
like a thousand bucks
you know the quality of what you have to
deliver is much higher than what you've
ever done so if you're good at
podcasting
or conference talks this is a totally
different ballgame there's another level
of density
and there's another level of community
building that just don't exist
in traditional uh talks that you give
when you aren't getting
you know paid for them and so what maven
does
primarily is we teach people how to
build cohort-based courses
and that is like a huge value add as
we're growing what we're realizing is
eventually people are going to know how
to teach cohort based courses and we
need to make those color-based courses
better
and so the model that we pursue or where
we're headed is
building software that makes maven
indispensable
as a product that makes your course
better so we just talked about community
right
i think eventually maven should be able
to solve the community problem for you
right now we solve it by teaching you or
we actually taught colton
how to build a community and helped
helped help onboard him and help him
think of it through it
but eventually actually we can match
people for you
we can help instru help students like
teach each other
on the platform and therefore you know
allow the instructor to have a course
that's broader than what they are
and so we're moving towards a world
where maven will be
a platform on which if you build your
course your course will be
so much better that it's worth building
it on maven
and we aren't necessarily a marketplace
because we think that the goal of maven
is to have uh is to enable the best
instructors
and we can enable the best instructors
if we bring all the
if we bring all the demand because it
changes your business model so if you
look at udemy
udemy doesn't enable the best
instructors udemy enables the best
students
because udemy is a marketing machine and
and the thing that udemy does super
super well is we
bring iudemy we bring students to
courses
but the instructors at the top end who
can bring their own students they don't
want to teach on udemy because
of that problem and so maven's goal is
to take
less of a percentage be more of an
enabler
than a creator uh and let the creators
build their own
courses and just make you as successful
as humanly possible
yeah it's very interesting as um you
know i've done a couple of these now
uh learning you know why are people
coming
and i thought it was going to be for
the education for the information right
walk away hey i didn't know something
now i know it
kind of checked that box that was worth
it uh but what i found was and you said
earlier it's like an outcome based thing
right they're coming for not just the
education in my case they're coming
because they want to get a job in the
industry so you have to meet a certain
quality bar
uh and you need to be able to um go
ahead and then
kind of hand them off or help them right
if that's what they're coming for
but i don't know if it'd be possible for
a platform
uh to bring those types of folks to me
right it's almost like a very
specialized
audience uh very specialized customer
base and so
um you know i'm much better suited to do
that than a platform is
but the platform is much better suited
to kind of empower me with all the tools
and
and uh you know operational excellence
than uh that i could do on my own right
yeah i mean just to play this back to
you i think the thing that makes you so
impressive as a creator
is just how willing you are to uh
partner offload uh sort of like work
with others to make your own world
bigger and what i found at maven
is that there are uh and with creators
in general is there's a
there's a real value in the multi
multiplicative approach
of having partners in different things
so like
at maven as an example it would be
insane if we were gonna
like run maven without partnering with
things like zoom
we partnered with slack right we use a
lot of other and then of course we
partner with investors right we have
a16z we have you
you know investing in our company and so
we really believe in this multiplicative
approach
to success and you've just done a great
job because you brought in colton and
you incentivized him and i think that
was like
the smartest move i've seen anyone make
we're actually going to try and
replicate it uh
to say hey if i have someone else
who is on my team helping me build this
and i give him the responsibility and
just let him run with it
and then i focus on what i'm good at
which is teaching and
obviously audience building those are
your two main strengths i mean you're an
incredible teacher i watched you know a
lot of your first
week you know your first lectures and
i'm sure that you've improved since then
even more
but you were just a natural um and i
think that's what maven does maven
provides you this like
it's just one of many tools that you
should have in your tool set as a
creator
uh and yeah i'm pretty proud of the way
that you've
that has worked out with you and i i
hope we can have more creators
who think of it in the way that you do
because i think you've you know you've
run your course you've been the most
successful creator on the platform
in part because of your willingness to
partner with colton and then of course
with us as well i think yeah and you
know for those that don't
know this about me i'm a huge believer
in this idea of like single threaded
leadership
right it's just uh for me i mean i got a
million things going on if i literally
spent all day trying to do all of them
by myself i would get nothing done
instead by essentially finding somebody
who
uh you know not it's not only competent
is ambitious and
um you know kind of is uh is successful
in their own right
and saying to them listen you're going
to be responsible for this specific body
of work
uh and you're going to reap the benefits
if it's successful
and you're also going to be to blame if
it's not um
it provides that focus right it provides
that kind of accountability
uh and responsibility and so um you know
it's something that
uh over the years i've just learned and
kind of replicated over and over again
and i also have a uh a point of i think
when somebody's responsible for
something uh they want it to be high
quality
right you're much more likely to uh kind
of skimp on quality if
it's the 14th most important thing
you're doing
doesn't seem like you need to focus on
quality as much as the number one most
important thing you're doing
uh and so when you have somebody who
that's their dedicated job or kind of
focus
you just actually get higher quality as
well so it's like higher quality feeds
back into more success more success
leads to
you know greater focus greater focus
leads back into kind of higher quality
and so it's this like very nice
uh you know kind of self-reinforcing uh
mechanism that you know so far has
worked really well and maybe has been a
big part of that colton's been a big
part of that
uh we'll just keep going amazing yeah
we're
we're so excited and i think that the
future
of what you're doing is is so such a big
opportunity right i mean
imagine if there's hundreds or thousands
of instructors like you
out there and i think eventually there
will be hundreds of thousands
of people who are taking their time
to teach the new generation the next
generation of leaders
uh what they know and you are just so
much better equipped to teach people
crypto
than any professor at any university
right i mean
i'd put you up there as as better than
literally almost anyone and that's
crazy that you in your current life
could never be a university professor
but you can be an instructor on maven
you can be an instructor on the internet
via podcasting and things
and so i'm really excited about finding
more people like you
who want to build their their brand and
their knowledge
and teach people what currently is not
really knowledge that is available out
there
um you know what you teach in your
course is pretty unique can't find it
anywhere else
speaking of hundreds of thousands of
instructors uh before we get to the
rapid fire questions just fast forward
maybe 10
15 20 years from now how do you see
maven kind of evolving and
what does this look like in kind of a
steady state once
you've been able to really build out the
team but out the platform
um and get a pretty big number of
instructors on the platform
maven's goal is to be the university of
the future you know
we really believe that there's an
opportunity right now to reset the
online the the education system broadly
through the internet through the online
learning
um angle and so we think that over the
next decade
uh we are going to inspire and
and empower a uh the largest faculty in
the world we want to build the largest
faculty of the best
instructors in the world and we think
that those people look a lot more like
you
and lee jin uh than they do look like
you know someone who got spent seven
years getting a phd
and then is getting tenure at some some
mid-range university
and so over time what does this mean
well it means that as we have more and
more courses
eventually we can provide more and more
outcomes so what if you
are taking a course on crypto and you
also have a course on recruiting
and then you also have a course on the
creator economy well if you combine
these three things
you can now work for a crypto focused
creator economy company as a recruiter
right and so you can imagine all sorts
of different
like opportunities where if you're on
maven and you're learning
you can learn from and you know anthony
popliano about one thing you can learn
from legion about another thing you can
learn from leni ruchitsky on product
management
or learn from someone on recruiting and
all these things combined
can become a much better education than
what you can get
uh you know anywhere else in the world
and so our goal is to empower
creators to become those professors of
the future so that eventually
there's you know literally on like
thousands or hundreds of thousands of
options for people
to learn that are far more effective and
more
engaging and higher quality than what
they have today
in the current system what's been the
most
uh surprising and maybe the most fun
thing
since you started uh going down this
path uh till today
the most surprising thing is just how
hard a cohort base course is to build
and run
i'm like i'm like amazed every time
at wes ko my co-founder she always is
like
you know this is hard this is
challenging and i think i've been just
amazed at watching
wes come up with ways to make it easier
for people
you know and so we're like getting
better and better every couple of months
and just making it easier so that if you
are thinking about running a core based
course
you can go through like our three to six
week program and you'll be
three to six months ahead of what you
would be or maybe even two years ahead
of what you would be
without it the most fun thing honestly
is uh team building i i i like i
you know yesterday my executive
assistant
um posted on on instagram
a post that she had been waiting on for
a couple of months
and she just talked about how she found
she feels like she found home
uh being at maven and honestly that like
that made me tear up i
i really was just amazed at the it's
just so fun
to be uh an important part of people's
lives um
so team building to me isn't just team
building within maven
uh you know within the company but
another anecdote is uh you know
we have a an instructor sahel bloom
who bought his first house uh using
proceeds from his maven
uh course and so just like the impact we
can have on people
uh the team being a broader group than
just the
uh impact on my employees but also the
impact on our instructors
and then of course the impact on
students like you had a student recently
who got a job in crypto you've had many
of them now at this point
who got jobs in crypto as a result of
taking your course
the impact is just it's hard to beat
yeah that's a great answer uh before i
let you go
um i usually ask everyone the same three
questions you'll get to ask me one at
the end
what's the most important book you think
you've ever read
the most important book i've ever read
uh
i i i think that the most important book
is not it's not going to fit
what most people think okay but it's
[ __ ] look is a tragedy of great power
politics by
john mearsheimer okay why that book
and i i don't even agree with everything
he says
uh but the reason it's the most
important book is because it opened my
eyes to a form
of thinking um first principles thinking
in a more of a show than a tall way
so this book is just so incredibly well
written and clear that it it introduced
me to
the idea of writing and thinking from a
first principle's way and explaining the
world in a certain way
and it also explained to me the downside
of that
which is that mirror shriver kind of
misses a lot of the nuances
of how great power politics actually
works um
but it was such a study for me and i
spent a lot of years of my life thinking
about
politics and how it works at that level
because of this book
that's a great answer uh second question
is
from our friends over at eight sleep i
now finally am sleeping on the eight
sleep bed
and they used to sleep five or six hours
i just turn it freezing cold and i sleep
like eight or nine hours
uh to the point where if i'm ever not
home
uh if i'm traveling or something i can't
wait to get back because i know i'm
gonna get a better night of sleep
uh and it's been completely
life-changing for me what's your sleep
schedule especially as you've kind of
started the business and started to grow
it now
i i'm absolutely a a nine hour asleep
guy so i get i get nine hours of sleep
ninety percent
of the of the nights i pretty much
always throw in the towel around ten or
eleven
i go to bed i also crank down the
temperature i don't have an eight sleep
yet because i'm kind of in transition
but i do plan on buying one
um nice and i i sleep
eight to nine hours every night and i
wake up and i
i almost always have my mornings blocked
off
not just so that i can work but also so
that i can sleep if i end up sleeping
really late
yeah that uh being able to get nine
hours like 90 of the time that's
fantastic so you are uh
you're an a plus student for that
question uh compared to most people
uh next one's more fun aliens are you a
believer or a non-believer
i'm a believer yeah i i think i think
it's hard
it's hard it's hard to imagine i haven't
spent enough time doing
actual math on it but it's hard to
imagine with the size of the universe
that there aren't aliens out there
i think the thing that people might miss
though that i personally i haven't again
haven't done the math on but
is that uh aliens are are out there
but time and space is is is a is it
do it's a two-part thing and so the
question is
not just where are the aliens but when
are they
and i don't know if it's clear that they
are gonna
overlap with us uh in the way
in the time and space because of the
because of the fact that it's two factor
and not one factor
i uh literally that's exactly what i
think is that they exist but we'll never
come in contact with them because
they're probably too far away or
different timing
uh so i i definitely agree uh you could
ask me one question to finish up what do
you got for me
tell me about the the biggest downside
to moving to miami
what do you miss the most
it's always going to be people like you
just wherever you live somewhere
uh you make a bunch of friends i've got
a number of friends that i'm very close
with that are still in new york
um you know they've come down here to
visit we've obviously gone back and seen
them
uh but that's really it uh you know and
it's kind of a weird like downside
because
uh just as you can't spend as much time
with certain people
it opens up the opportunity to spend
more time with other people
and so you got to kind of take that
balance
of if you have high quality friends and
you know wherever you were and in let's
say miami
uh it's okay uh but that's probably the
biggest downside it's just you
get used to hanging out with certain
friends and enjoy it
and then if you move uh they're not
there anymore right and so
you can facetime and do all that it's
just not the same
yeah i i have the same feeling about any
place that i've lived in so i can
totally relate to that
well paul thanks so much for having me
on i really enjoyed this
absolutely where can we send people to
find you on twitter and find out more
about maven
maven uh zz it's maven.com
m-a-v-e-n uh very proud of having gotten
that domain name
and and i'm also very easy because my
name is very unique so
i'm assuming it'll be in the show title
etc but it's gaganbiani
on twitter and it's gaganbiani.com
if you want to join my newsletter again
on the website uh
gog and biany maven pretty easy
that is uh very simple so i highly
suggest people go follow you on twitter
too you got some great uh great tweets
so
keep that up as well and we will
definitely do this again in the future
as you guys keep going
sounds good thanks bob really appreciate
it